. OK.
The David Pakman Show subreddit breaking new
records, I think because everybody's home
and has not that much to do.
David Pakman dot com slash read it where nearly
19000 of our viewers and listeners participate
in respectful, moderated political and news
discussions.
Green blue ninety-eight.
Posting that the postal service is warning
it may have to.
It may have to close as soon as June unless
they get some support.
You know, what's going on with the postal
service is really horrible.
I had to go into the post office earlier this
week.
Post office here in Boston.
It's very, very ugly.
It was completely packed.
People were working and they had some protective
equipment, but they are doing what they can
to try to mitigate the risk of contagion.
We, of course, need the postal service.
But at the same time, the more understaffed
the postal service is, the more people have
to wait in line.
I just got the hell out of there.
I mean, I just decided, you know what?
It's not that important to send this stuff.
And I told people it's not going out right
now.
I'm not going to stand in the post office,
you know, for an hour, waiting in line, exposing
myself and and other people.
But it's only going to get worse if the postal
service ends up having to shutter completely.
We are depending on things being able to be
shipped around related to fighting the virus.
The postal workers aren't being treated the
right way.
At the same time, this is a service that we
need.
It's a complete and total mess.
And of course, the stimulus package includes
no money, no money for the postal service,
a major, major problem.
There was a very interesting post by Fidel
Supe on the subreddit asking when the show
is recorded and when it gets uploaded.
And the answers to those questions are easy.
We record in the early afternoon and upload
in the sort of mid to late afternoon.
But one of our good friends, Brody, who has
called in regularly, put together a sort of
guide to how to call into the show and be
a good caller.
And it's an absolutely beautiful guide.
And clearly, Brody also has a lot of time
on his hands.
But it's so great because Brody explains,
listen, there is etiquette here that you need
to understand.
If you hear another caller, ask the same thing
you were going to ask.
Think of another question or hang up.
Because two callers in a row with the same
question doesn't make for a good show.
Brody points out, Don't be discouraged if
you don't always get your call picked up on.
There are many people on hold and I can only
take so many calls.
I love that, Brody says speak clearly and
with a full tone of voice.
So David can hear you consider not calling
in when you're going to be moving around in
a car or whatever.
It's not going to be good.
And Brody also explains that it's normal to
feel nervous.
But consider writing your question out, which
is an excellent, excellent suggestion.
And maybe most importantly, Brody says, get
to your question very quickly.
Go right into the question and then listen
to what I say so that we can have like a real
conversation.
Sometimes people have two things written down.
No matter what I say to the first one, they
go to the second one.
So these are beautiful, beautiful tips from
Brody.
I really appreciate him putting that together.
And I believe that if we all work together,
we will successfully increase the spread of
good phone calls, good phone calls to the
show.
And I look forward to hearing from more people.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash.
Read it.